he's a TJ watt the Wisconsin Badgers
linebacker I think it's been nine
consecutive years that there's been at
least one watt with the with the Badgers
TJ joins us now teach a good morning how
are you how's it going things are having
me out
how's your motr right now the motors
running the motors always running it's
nonstop I like that we did a lot of
research on you and someone said that I
should ask you what your apartment looks
like at Christmas time oh boy there are
Christmas decorations up they've been up
for a couple weeks now there are lights
everywhere just fully in the Christmas
mood ready to go Jim a tree I have three
of them three trees three trees and a
little three-bedroom apartment just
every bedroom get a tree I don't mind
has one I don't know about my roommates
for this tool in the living room as well
so just just trying to spread some
holiday cheer um if the watt family
fought the Gronkowski's well I think
you'd be a mismatch because I think
there's more of them there let's say I
it was three on three well then they'd
get an argument probably about picking
what three are gonna fight that's truth
you willing if I if I had JJ against
drunk how great would that battle be it
would be a great battle I couldn't tell
you who to win that battle would be a
great battle right baby so a lot of take
us to see the hell you got to pick your
brother well or maybe you don't I drove
my brother just cuz I've seen what he
can do he's given it to me a couple
times has he ever won up you know did he
ever beat you up uh yeah I'll say yeah I
tried to fight back a couple times but
yeah he gave I was on the bad end of it
a couple times but you're breaking all
of his records didn't you you broke his
shotput record in high school didn't you
yeah and usually I had more training
than him and all that so his excuses
that come along with it and more sacks
than him at Wisconsin yeah that as well
so uh hopefully I can keep it going
do you care where you're ranked right
now I do not at all to be honest do you
know where you
ranked I think six or seven somewhere in
there top ten I know okay be is the
feeling that if you win the Big Ten do
you deserve to be in the Final Four I
don't know and the thing is I don't
think in all honesty is as cliche as it
sounds I don't think we're thinking
about it because it's in the committee's
hands 100% and no matter what we do we
just have to take care of business this
weekend and let the rest can take care
of itself best team you played this year
oh I have to go with though either a
house a to Michigan just because we
couldn't get the job done it took off it
took a whole team effort to scheme
against them and obviously we didn't get
it done so they were prior to toughest
opponents what's the difference between
those two teams I say just a style of
offenses as a defensive player Omaha se
has a spread offense and Michigan has a
little bit more of a power offense power
runoff and so just preparing for the two
different styles a little bit different
for a defensive flare how can your
brother or brother's since you have to
in the pros help you if you ask for
advice
oh well just first of all just having a
two older brothers have been through the
process so just the little things like
school works they can help me um just
de-stress if I'm stressed out about all
the things about college or when it
comes to football I can talk to Derek
about how fullback stay up certain
blocks or how they block certain schemes
so I can fight against powerful vaccine
to block me and then JJ more this year
since had more free time I've talked to
him about pass-rush me was and how to
stop the run and certain things so it
definitely has its positives on both
aspects of just being brothers and on
the football field talking to TJ watt
the Wisconsin Badgers linebacker joining
us Dan Patrick show who's your
quarterback this weekend I don't know
that's a good question
I play defense every cover let's shout
the offensive side of all I'm serious
come on TV bar Houston Alex Hornibrook I
will tell you that right now what I
don't know which one um oh that's not
for me to decide either all right well
maybe you could give us a little you
know inside scoop here
I'll play the defense is going to be
flying around having a fun time are you
allowed to hit the quarterbacks at all
no I cannot you may give him a
protection bubble I cannot enter at all
what happened to your yeah you get a
good scolding and you'll probably yelled
at and take it out for a few plays but
that's pushed the envelope and camp a
little bit not not this late in the
season what's your major retailer and
consumer behavior what the hell is dad
TJ studying just why people buy in the
retail world product placement just
saying things like that
do you understand Black Friday I do
never done it though why is it so crazy
why do people act you know how the body
experiences because they go crazy over
the deals man is there's a great deals I
guess and it's a time a year where
people are off of work and they can go
out and spend their money get crazy
your dad was he a fireman is you still a
fireman
my dad is a tired fireman we were named
Plus you as I believe Oh
who gets more women football players or
firemen I'd have to say a fireman yes
I'm gonna go with my dad got my my
lovely mother of course he did that's a
tough business to be able to do that
yeah definitely I respect everything
firemen do I know he went through a lot
especially throughout the holidays he
wasn't there a lot of the time did you
ever go work did you ever go to work
with him yeah a couple times
oh we grew up running around the
ambulances run around the firehouse
eating with the guys and all that stuff
so it's a great great camaraderie over
at the firehouse I loved growing up in
that atmosphere did you get to slide
down the fire pole a couple times of
course you did of course you did well
good luck against Penn State and maybe
making it to the Final Four and hope
your motor continues to run high alright
well thank you for having me that's TJ
want the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
you